في السعوديه اثر خبر حول مجلس حول ان مجلس
الشورى سيصوت الاثنين المقبل على توصيات
تقرير هيئه النقل بعد مطالبه احد الاعضاء
لتطبيق نظام التوطين لمندوبي تطبيقات
التوصيل والنقل الكثير من الجدل حول جدوى
تطبيقه تابع المزيد حوله في التقرير
التالي
توطين مندوبي تطبيقات التوصيل والنقل
بالسعوديه بين مد وجزر واقع حبيس بين
انظمه تحفيزيه من جهه ومطالبات بفرض قانون
لتطبيقه من جهه اخرى اخر المحاولات توجه
مجلس الشورى للتصويت في جلسته المقبله في
توصيات تقرير هيئه النقل لتطبيق نظام
التوطين للمندوبين بشكل عاجل بحسب صحيفه
الرياض التي قالت ان توصيه التقرير جاءت
بعد مطالبه عضو مجلس الشورى عبد الله
النجار وبالتنسيق مع وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه بتطبيق
التوطين الذي اكد ان التوسع في استخدام
التطبيقات الالكترونيه في السعوديه ادى
الى دخول الكثير من غير المواطنين في خدمه
التوصيل دون ضوابط بالرغم من اعلان وزير
النقل سابقا البدء في سعوده القطاع اعلان
اللاق الكثير من ردود الفعل غير المؤيده
والتي اعتبرت ان فرض القرار سيقلل من جوده
الخدمه في ظل الطلب المتزايد والمتسارع نت
منها
[موسيقى]
مطالبات تاتي وسط تضخم كبير لارقام
الطلبات عبر تطبيقات التوصيل حيث بلغت
وفقا لاحصائيات لهيئه الاتصالات وتقنيه
المعلومات اكثر من 28 مليون طلب فقط خلال
الربع الاول من العام 2021
لتفتح ابواب الشكوك حول ما اذا كانت توطين
سيساهم في خلق وظائف جديده امام السعوديين
دون الاخلال بمستوى الجوده ام سيكون
بمثابه سكين في عنق التوسع الذي توصلت
اليه هذه البرامج
ينضم الينا من الرياضه المستثمر في
الشركات الناشئه مشهوره بيان اهلا بك معنا
سيد مشهور بدايه يعني برايك لماذا هذا
الرفض الكبير لهذا المقترح بتوطين قطاع
التوصيل
لسبب بسيط جدا لان الان الطلب
التوصيل المتزايد الان تطبيقات التوصيل
تتفاوت اعداد الطلبات اليوميه فيها حسب
تطبيق التوصيل طبعا ممكن مئه الف طلب في
اليوم الى 300 الف او اكثر طلب في اليوم
طبعا تتفاوت حسب تطبيق التوصيل الطلب ضخم
جدا بالمقابل للعرض من ناحيه سائقين
بالكاد يغطي هذا الطلب فيتم حصر
السائقين على السائقين السعوديين فقط
فبيكون في خلل كبير بين العرض والطلب وهذا
بلا شك سيؤثر على الاسعار وسياثر قبل ما
يؤثر حتى على التطبيقات التوصيل سياثر على
المطاعم والمحلات والمتاجر الشركه مع هذه
التطبيقات بحيث تنخفض عدد الطلبات لديها
بشكل كبير فلا اعتقد ان القرار مدروس بشكل
جيد وان تم سيكون اثر سلبي بشكل كبير على
هذا القطاع كما اثر بشكل سلبي على قطاع او
تطبيقات توصيل
التطبيقات مثل كريم واوبر مختصه في
المشاوير طيب السيد مشهور يعني برايك
لماذا يمكن ان يكون هناك تفاوت وفرق
كبير بين الطلب ويعني الطلب كما حضرتك
تفضلت اذا هل هناك عدم رغبه من الجانب
السعودي او الشباب السعودي للدخول في هذا
القطاع
اعتقد ان الوظيفه
كسائق توصيل ضربات وظيفه غير مغريه
للسعودي اللي عده اسباب اولها نوع الوظيفه
يختلف تماما حتى عن توصيل او عن تطبيقات
المشاوير من ناحيه انه يتطلب انتظار طويل
عند المطاعم او عند المحلات لتوصيل
الطلبات يتطلب حتى التعامل مع روائح الاكل
ونقل
المنتجات بمختلف اشكالها وروائحها
وانواعها ايضا يتطلب كفاءه عاليه في
التوصيل بحيث ان الموظف الواحد يجب ان
نتمكن من التوصيل على عدد كبير من الطلبات
في اليوم الواحد ليحصل على دخل مجزي
اجمالا هي وظيفه لا تعتمد لا تتطلب اي
مهارات وانما تتطلب قد تعتمد بشكل كبير
نوعيه الوظيفه هذه على الاعمال التي
ربما يعني بالنسبه لها الدخل الضعيف لهذه
الوظائف نسبيا
لا يسبب مشكله بالنسبه لهم وما عندهم
مشكله نضيف الى ذلك سيد مشهور ربما ايضا
يعني الطموح المهني لدى الشباب السعودي
ربما لا يتناسب ايضا مع هذه الوظيفه يعني
لا يستطيعون ان يتقدموا على سلم الوظيفي
ربما فيها
صحيح بحكم انه هذه الوظيفه لا تتطلب اي
مهارات بالتالي لا توفر اي مهارات ممكن ان
تطور هذه شباب سعودي ولا توفر حتى مستقبل
واضح الى للشاب اذا بدا اليوم كسائق او
كمندوب توصيل وين ممكن يتوجه بعد كذا
اعتقد الافضل التركيز على سواء على ممكن
الوظائف الاشرافيه المتعلقه في هذه القطاع
ممكن
التمكين رواد الاعمال الذي يعملون مع هذه
تطبيقات توصيل الاعمال على قوانين وانظمه
جديده تنظم عمل بين التطبيقات التوصيل
والتجار بدلا من محاوله توطين القطاع طيب
برايك هل عدد العاملين الان في قطاع
التوصيل هو كافي ليتناسب مع العرض والطلب
الان حتى مع كون اغلب قطاع التوصيل غير
سعوديين الا انه بالكاد يكفي لتلبيه الطلب
وحتى العامل الواحد اليوم في تطبيق
التوصيل غالبا يعمل لدى اكثر من تطبيق ومع
ذلك التطبيقات تجد صعوبه في تلبيه الطلبات
المتزايده على التطبيقات فمجرد الزام هذه
التطبيقات على سعوده جميع مناديب التوصيل
بلا شك تتواجد صعوبه كبيره في تربيه
الطلبات المتزايده وايضا سيعكس هذا سلبا
سواء العدد الطلبات التي تصل للتجار او
عدد الطلبات او عفوا على سعر التوصيل الذي
يضطر الى دفع المستهلك النهايه طيب ما
الحلول اللي ممكن يستفيد منها قطعه توصيل
يعني خصوصا انه في مطالبات الان بسعوده
القطاع في الحين ارى ايضا معارضه جدا بسبب
التجارب السابقه اللي ربما بقت بالفشل
عندما يعني تم توطينها برايك يعني التوطين
هل يناسب جميع القطاعات من ضمنها قطاع
التوصيل
هذه قطاعات قطاع التوصيل
توطينا في النهايه نحتاج الى وظائف تبني
مهارات وامكانات لدى شباب البلد تمكنهم من
القيام بوظائف اكبر وتساهم في اقتصاد
البلد بشكل اكبر في المستقبل بدلا من
حصرهم على وظائف قد لا تفيد سواء تفيدهم
حاليا وتفيد مستقبله ومستقبل البلد في شكل
كبير هناك مشاكل اكبر في قطاع التوصيل
الطلبات قد تتعلق في المشاكل الموجوده
حاليا او التحديات الموجوده بين التجار
وبين التطبيقات قد تتعلق في الانظمه
والقوانين هناك مكنه اخرى من امكان التفات
لها وتطويرها بدلا من التفات لموضوع
التطوير التوطين الذي اعتقد انه لن يثمر
بنا
ابدا توجه له طيب بشكل عام وما ان يعني
اقدموا على توطين هذا القطاع هل ممكن انه
يؤثر يعني بالتاكيد راح ياثر على القطاع
نفسه ولكن ما نظرنا الى الصوره الاكبر
يعني هل يمكن ان يؤثر بشكل عام على قطاع
النقل على قطاع الاقتصادي في السعوديه
ربما بما انه جانب كبير يعني
عدد كبير ونسبه كبيره من المواطنين
السعوديين والمقيمين يستخدمون هذه
التطبيقات
اقتصاديا او اقتصادي بشكل
تعتمد بنسبه قد تصل الى 50% او اكثر على
الطلبات الوارده لها تكون من تطبيقات
التوصيل فلن تتمكن من تعويض هذه الطلبات
وتعويض الايرادات التي تخسرها نتيجه هذا
القرار ولن تتمكن تعويضها قنوات اخرى
فسيكون ضرر الاقتصادي كبير من وجهه نظري
قد يؤدي الى اغلاق الكثير من المتاجر بسبب
انعدام تلك القناه الفعاله التي تولد لهم
الكثير من الطلبات وبالتالي انعدام
الايرادات الوارده لهم من تلك القنوات
التوجه نحن نحو التوطنات
سلبي فقط ولن يكون له اي فوائد ايجابيه
للبلد شكرا جزيلا لك من الرياض المستثمر
في الشركات الناشئه مشهوره بيان لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات